für präsident marco der eine zweite
amtszeit anstrebt haben sie im
nordfranzösischen dünner kaum etwas
übrig den brauchen wir nicht ihm geht es
doch nur um die polizei und marine
jungen haben in der ersten runde firma
cross herausforderin vom rechten rand
gestimmt für marine le pen sowie mehr
als 40 prozent der wähler hier wenige
tage vor der stichwahl geben sie sich
siegesgewiss
in marie le pen muss um die macht kommen
wir haben diese regierung setzt die sich
nicht um uns kümmert der 52 jährige hat
früher auf baustellen gejobbt heute
drückt er wieder die schulbank woche für
woche machen ihnen steigende
lebensmittelpreise zu schaffen sorgen
auf die marine le pen bei ihren
wahlkampf touren eingeht seit monaten
schon
sie engagiert sich für uns in frankreich
zum beispiel will sie die mehrwertsteuer
senken
er war früher banker ist einer der das
geld liebt marie le pen liegt frankreich
und so hat es für sie nichts anrüchiges
extrem rechts zu wählen im gegenteil sie
sprechen von tante marie zeigen voller
stolz gemeinsame fotos hier im einstigen
stahl und kohle revier gingen in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten tausende jobs
verloren heute lebt knapp die hälfte der
bevölkerung unter der armutsgrenze
glücksversprechen kommen gut an jobs
wohnungen dabei will die franzosen vor
rechte einräumen diesen rechtsruck
finden in der nur wenige bedenklich
josef bucher hat seinen stand am rande
des marktes aufgebaut
das wird nicht nur außenpolitisch
reibereien geben wenn sie gewinnt auch
bei uns im land ich habe große sorge das
wird uns spalten
habe sich die stimmung im land verändert
diskriminierung zugenommen
frankreich steht vor einer
richtungsentscheidung die möglichkeit
dass das land künftig von einer
nationalisten regiert wird ist größer
denn je von einer frau die sich von
putins russland hat fördern lassen die
der eu den kampf angesagt hat und die
die zusammenarbeit mit deutschland
aufkündigen will
deutschland steht im absoluten
widerspruch zum geopolitischen
selbstverständnis frankreich das sich
auf unabhängigkeit abschreckung eine
armee und industrie von weltrang stützt
in anbetracht dieser unterschiede werden
wir die zusammenarbeit mit berlin
beenden
europa in auflösung
markus leuthe tun dieser tage alles um
das zu verhindern ein arbeiter und
studenten viertel in lille die
wahlkämpferin malbeck zieht mit ihrer
truppe jeden nachmittag von tür zu tür
mit makros botschaften erreichen sie nur
wenige der unentschlossenen viele wollen
einen ungültigen stimmzettel abgeben
ich gehe wählen ja aber weder firma kaum
noch für marin
aber wollen sie die extrem rechte nicht
aufhalten
ja schon aber ich bin weder mit dem
einen noch mit der anderen einverstanden
genau um sie geht es hier um die die im
ersten wahlgang wieder für makro noch
für element gestimmt haben die die nun
hadern überhaupt zur stichwahl zu gehen
es könnte knapp werden vor allem viele
linke wähler tun sich schwer
ich hätte mir gewünscht dass der linke
kandidat john lelangue schon klar
stellung bezieht indem er nicht nur sagt
wird nicht für lücken sondern auch wählt
nicht ungültig wird aktiv
aktiv für marco wirkt vor allem marco
selbst lange hatte er sich im wahlkampf
frage macht der außenpolitik priorität
eingeräumt in der so viele phillip ens
gestimmt haben gibt er sich nun volksnah
diskutiert stunden lang mit den
bewohnern denken sie an die kleinen
leute ja ich habe sie im blick sie leben
in armut
darum kämpfen wir schaffen arbeitsplätze
markus bilanz spricht auf den ersten
blick für ihn die zahl der arbeitslosen
ist zurückgegangen liegt bei gut 7
prozent
mit geldprämien hat der staat steigende
kosten abgefedert in der pandemie und
nun während des ukraine kriegs und doch
fordern viele mehr unterstützung der
aufschwung kommt längst nicht bei allen
an julia wenn ist automechaniker ohne
festen job war zeitweise wohnungslos er
lebt von grundsicherung hilft
ehrenamtlich in einem sozial kaufhaus
aus der vierfache vater nimmt markus
wahlprogramm abwegig vor allem den
vorschlag sozialhilfeempfänger zu
arbeitsstunden zu verpflichten
leute wie ich komme nur mit
schwierigkeiten durch den monat und das
einzige was ihnen dazu einfällt ist dass
wir 20 stunden arbeiten
und das alles führt dazu dass sie marine
le pen wählen
ich wähle marion luppen weder le pens
nähe zu russland noch ihre distanz zu
deutschland stören ihn der täglich um
seine existenz kämpft internationales
spielt für die wahlentscheidung keine
rolle das bekommen wir nicht nur hier zu
hören
wir haben unsere sorgen an höchster
stelle vorgetragen und nichts ist
passiert
immer gibt es ausreden dabei liegt so
viele wagen mit wenigen zugeständnissen
wäre uns schon geholfen
zum beispiel heißt es es gäbe keine
wohnungen aber für ukraine werden
plötzlich wohnungen bereitgestellt das
ist nicht fair auch wenn ich ihre
situation bedauert
auf die stimmen der unzufriedenen setzt
marine le pen sie tritt inzwischen
weniger radikal auf doch an ihrem
leitgedanken frankreich den franzosen
hält sie fest sollte sie präsidentin
werden würde das nicht nur das land es
würde ganz europa verändern